tenemos tres dibujos distintos y me
pregunta para iniciar este asunto es
cuál de estos representa 20 dividido
entre 4 pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta
bien vayamos a ver cada uno de estos
dibujos y es más vamos a pensar en qué
representa cada uno de ellos
primero cuántos círculos tengo en este
dibujo de aquí
veamos tengo uno dos tres cuatro y
después tengo cuatro grupos de cuatro es
decir 4 8 12 16 entonces esto se ve como
16 círculos divididos por 4 podemos
pensarlo como grupos de cuatro o pensar
que está dividido en cuatro grupos
iguales ambas ideas son correctas y
podemos ver que esto nos da igual a
cuatro así que este de aquí lo que
realmente está representando es 16 entre
4 no 20 entre 4
ahora que hay del siguiente bueno aquí
parece que tenemos uno dos tres cuatro
cinco grupos de uno dos tres cuatro
cinco círculos entonces este se ve como
veinticinco círculos dividido en grupos
de cinco o dividido entre cinco grupos
iguales lo cual por supuesto es igual a
cinco por lo tanto este es 25 entre 5 y
no es 20 entre 4
ahora que hay de este bueno tenemos 1 2
3 4 5 círculos y tenemos uno dos tres
cuatro grupos de cinco círculos por lo
tanto son cinco diez quince veinte
entonces en definitiva tenemos veinte
círculos aquí y los tenemos divididos
entre cuatro grupos iguales que es
exactamente con lo que iniciamos la
plática esto es 20 entre 4 20 dividido
entre 4 y puedes ver que cuando tomas el
20 y lo divides por cuatro grupos
iguales obtienes 1 2 3 4 5 círculos por
grupo y hemos acabado